hop
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour la conférence d'evian un avion a
amené à genève les membres de la
délégation fln conduite par monsieur
belkacem krim et qui comprend messieurs
boumendjel et ahmed francis qui
résultats le 3 toutes les tendances du
fln et à sa descente d'avion
monsieur belkacem krim a évoqué le sens
général des revendications et phelep
quand nous avons eu l'occasion de le
déclarer
l'algérie veut accéder à la vie
internationale sans complexe avec le
désir sincère de coopérer avec tous les
peuples et d'apporter sa modeste
contribution au progrès humain
c'est dans une villa genevoise la villa
du bois davout transformée en camp
retranché et sévèrement gardés par
l'armée la police helvétique que la
délégation fln a établi son quartier
général
[Musique]
c'est de là que le matin du samedi 20
mai les délégués se sont envolés à bord
de trois hélicoptères pour rejoindre
evian
[Musique]
evian l'hôtel du parc la police fait
toujours aussi bonne garde
monsieur louis joxe ministre d'état pour
les affaires d'algérie chef de la
délégation française arrive le premier
journalistes et caméras sont parqués à
distance respectueuse
la délégation fln pénètre à son tour à
l'hôtel du parc
nous ne verrons rien de plus mais en
même temps un grand feu s'est produit la
france a ordonné en algérie un
cessez-le-feu unilatéral
du côté français les armes se taisent
sauf cas de légitime défense
conférence d'evian cessez-le-feu
français sommes-nous enfin en vue de
l'aboutissement l'hymne à l'heure de la
feria les vieilles arènes romaines sont
comme toujours en pareille occasion
plein à craquer nîmes est aujourd'hui en
espagne
et voici antonio ordonez le beau frère
de dominique green qui lui donne à
l'investiture
l'alternative en langage tauromachique
depuis ordonniez c'est devenu son rival
certains disent sont égales
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quelles qualités faut-il pour être aux
toreros le courage et le style le
courage ils sont beaucoup qui n'en
manque pas le style
il faut regarder hors d'agnès
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ah ah
le festival de cannes s'est terminée
comme il convient au cinéma sous une
pluie d'étoilés
la palme d'or du grand prix a été
attribué à deux films ex-aequo viridiana
de l'espagnol luis bunuel et une aussi
longue absence du français henri colpi
[Musique]
en même temps le prix d'interprétation
féminine revenait à sophia loren pour
son rôle de la cades chara et le prix
d'interprétation masculine à anthony
perkins pour sa création d mais vous
brahms
c'est fini le rideau tombe pour m
[Musique]
distribution des prix également à bari
mais pour les forains littérature marie
morgane maurice genevoix jean bertho un
membre du jury ont salué la victoire du
lauréat du prix sève de la croix andré
langue que le maréchal juin à féliciter
pour son livre bagages à la consigne
la photographie elle a tenu salon à la
bibliothèque nationale ce qui a donné
l'occasion de constater que l'art du
portrait ne pêchait pas à l'origine par
excès d'imagination l'appareil mystère
sacré ne bougeait pas quant aux patients
jeu d'attitude réduit appuyé à droite
appuyée à gauche ou face aux penseurs
[Musique]
et
il faut dire pourtant qu'avec nadar et
ses modèles théophile gautier eugène
delacroix et victor hugo à 50 et à 80
ans le portraitiste gagna ses lettres de
noblesse mais comme pour toulouse
lautrec le portrait rester généralement
enlisé dans les vues générales ainsi
henri rochefort et sarah bernhardt
aujourd'hui l'art du portrait à d'autres
ambitions
il interprète et l'on peut suivre à
travers les portraits qu'on fait d'un
même modèle 30 photographes différents
l'étonnante aventure d'un visage tantôt
lumineux est comme saisi par un étrange
ban pureté lanto au contraire devenue le
reflet de force inquiétante
l'art du portrait
un salon chasse l'eau et c'est à n'en
pas douter avec avidité que les esprits
affamés de nouveautés se pencheront sur
ce bureau qu'on peut le plus aisément du
monde transformer en lit parfait pour
ses bourreaux de travail qui ne quittent
leurs dossiers qu journée sans cette
invention compte parmi les plus
vertigineuses du concours lépine de
cette année qui en offrent quelques
autres le clignotant rétractable pour
vélos matters par exemple ou encore
l'auto pédales d'un maniement
extrêmement commode et qui réhabilite
loto à pédales de nos enfants quant aux
tâches les plus tenaces
on peut désormais les supporter en toute
sérénité puisque dit on
rien ne résiste plus à l'action du super
rénovateurs
[Musique]
enfin une nouveauté qui réjouira tous
les pêcheurs la can a lancé qui projette
automatiquement la cuillère à 16 mètres
et qui permet de ne plus se soucier des
berges broussailleuse enfin
[Musique]
on songe aux trésors d'ingéniosité qu'il
fallait jusqu'ici déployé pour arriver à
lancer cette pauvre cuillère sans risque
et d'accrocher une branche au passage on
n'avait rien trouvé de mieux que le lens
fusée mais tout de même la méthode
sentait son bricole et puis il valait
mieux savoir nager
[Musique]
après traque la pentecôte
des milliers d'automobilistes ont repris
la route cette fois encore tous ne sont
pas revenus
or les accidents de la route non pas
pour cause qu'un hasard ou une
défaillance il y à aussi l'alcool mais
si l'ivresse caractérisé n'appelle aucun
commentaire il n'en va pas de même des
simples pause alcoolisées on ne se méfie
pas assez de l'agréable état d'euphorie
procuré par quelques modestes verre
[Musique]
d'alcool ainsi répandus dans le sang
provoque pourtant la perte de 30% de
l'acuité visuelle de 38% de l'acuité
auditive
[Musique]
il n'est jusqu'aux joyeux repas prise
innocemment même famille qui depuis se
transformer une sortie dominicale en
voyage pour l'éternité
alors en prenant le volant méfiez-vous
du bien-être suspect que procure
l'alcool
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ces horizons ces rivières n'ont pas
changé mais non plus ses hommes de la
nouvelle guinée que dans son film le
ciel et la boue nous présente pierre
dominique gayssot ils sont dans leurs
parures et dans leur rythme dans leurs
usagers dans leur vie pareil à ce que
découvrit dans ses voyages le capitaine
cook qui fut grand découvreur dit
l'inconnu au temps où la terre et est
encore vaste et mystérieuse
[Applaudissements]
au son des tambours sacrés plusieurs
tribus se réunissent aujourd'hui pour la
grande fête des esprits sur la berge les
femmes très habillée comme on le voit
attendent les hommes qui mime les gestes
du combat qui chassera les démos
[Applaudissements]
ses démons les voici cinq jeunes gens
masqués de la tête aux pieds personnifie
les puissances mauvaise qu'il faut
chasser loin du village et pas à pas la
procession sarrance le long du fleuve
poussant devant elle les cinq démos qui
l'on ne saura pas ce qu'ils sont devenus
rites étranges sorti du fond des temps
nous sommes revenus au premier âge du
mot
[Musique]